>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Joan Weeks: Good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to the African and Middle East
Division of the Library of Congress.
Today's lecture on the
discovery of Karamanlidika:
Disappearing Literature,
Artifacts and Cultural Heritage
by Selenay Aytac and Constantia
Constantinou is sponsored
by the Near East Section of the
African and Middle East Division.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the Near East Section.
On behalf of all my colleagues and
in particular Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb
who unfortunately can't be with us
today, she's chief of the division,
I'd like to welcome you to our
very special program today.
But before we get started I always
like to give a brief overview
of the division and in the
hopes that you'll come back
to use our collections
for your research.
This division is comprised
of three sections that build
and serve our collections to
researchers from around the world.
We cover 78 countries and
more than 35 languages.
The Africa Section includes all the
countries of Sub-Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic Section is responsible
for Judaica and Hebraica worldwide
and the Near East Section covers all
of the Arab countries including
North Africa, Turkey, Iran,
Afghanistan, Central Asia, the
Muslims in Western China, Russia,
the Balkans and the
peoples of the Caucasus,
so you see we encompass
a very wide region.
After the program we'd invite you
to fill in the evaluation forms
that you see on your chairs,
if you could kindly do that.
We like to see how we're
doing with our programs.
And also we have a little brochure
about our 4 Corners Blog posts.
We like to promote those to
enhance the ability for researchers
around the world to know what
we have here in our collections.
And also, I'd just
quickly remind you
that our program today is being
videotaped so if you ask questions,
just implicitly you're giving your
permission so please don't hesitate
but just to be aware that
it is being recorded.
So, now I'd like to
introduce our speakers,
Dr. Selenay Aytac is
an Associate Professor
at Long Island University
and a Fulbright Scholar.
She just finished her
Fulbright Scholarship
so that's quite an accomplishment.
She conducted her doctoral research
in the field of bibliometrics.
That's a very esoteric
field to say the least
and she studied scholarly
communication
and the behavior of
Turkish scientists.
She's also interested
in user studies,
particularly serving
diverse student groups
such as international
students in academic libraries.
And Dr. Constantia Constantinou
is Dean of University Libraries
at Stoney Brook University in New
York and also a Fulbright Scholar.
And she's published and presented
her research on topics ranging
from organizational performance,
information of literacy,
information systems, library
technology, digital preservation,
scholarly communication, so you
can see she's had a wide range
of interests.
And she's an established
public speaker.
She's been invited to present her
research at library conferences
in the United States and worldwide
including China, Cyprus, Finland,
France, Greece, Turkey, Korea,
Russia, Ukraine, Croatia,
Hong Kong, Spain, it goes on.
So, Constantia is always
co-editor of the book
"International Librarianship:
Developing Professional Interculture
and Educational Leadership".
Please help me welcome Doctors Aytac
and Constantinou to the podium.
[ Applause ]
>> Constantia Constantinou:
Good afternoon everyone,
what a pleasure to be here.
Thank you for your hospitality and
for the great honor to invite us
to the Library of Congress,
the Division of African
and Middle Eastern Division
to present our research.
My name is Constantia and
I'm delighted to be here
with my colleague Selenay
though we met accidentally
when I was finishing my
Fulbright coming from Cyprus
and she was getting ready to go
to Turkey to start her Fulbright
on the same research topic that
we both had fallen in love with.
Our research topic is on the
discovery of Karamanlidika.
To paraphrase a scholar by the name
of Matthias Kappler from his book
"A Tale of Two Languages:
Tracing the History of Turkish
and Greek Language", no
society is purely monolingual
and no human expression of art
or communication is monocultural
and this is what Selenay
and I came to discover
in our respective countries
and cultures.
The outline of our presentation
will talk about the origins
of Karamanlidika, Karamanlidika
terminology, our Fulbright projects
and what brought us into this kind
of research, the people of Cyprus
as have been divided and
reunited in their own cultures,
the Karamanlidika digital library
that Selenay's project is addressing
and some recommendations that
we, came from our research.
The origins of Karamanlidika
and Karamanlides
and the Karamanli people
started from 1071
when Turks began to
settle in Anatolia.
And the indigenous population of
Anatolia spoke and wrote Greek
and they were Greek Orthodox.
But nevertheless Turks
did not call them Greek
but they followed the Arab tradition
of calling them 'Rum'
which meant Romans.
And among this community
there was a group of Turkish
who wrote in Greek alphabet.
They lived in places in Anatolia
such as Karaman region, Konya,
Mersin, Silike, Kayseri, Yozgat,
Ankara and later because of trade
and economy some of them
settled in the cities
such as Trabzan, Izmir
and Instanbul.
This shaded map shows the area
of Karaman in relation to Turkey,
Greece, Cyprus and
Mykonos [phonetic].
And the next map gives us a better.
It's a historical map, a better
understanding where the region is
by name and shading of colors.
The Karaman region is the Greek
region right in the middle
of Anatolia above Cyprus.
Now, there are two theories
about the Karaman leaders.
The Karaman leaders were descended
from religiously-converted
Turkish soldiers, the Turcopoles,
that Byzantine emperors
settled in Anatolia.
And another theory that seems to
be a little more convincing is
that the Karaman leaders
are the direct descendants
of Byzantine Greeks.
Despite their linguistic
Turkification they maintain their
Greek Orthodox faith and we
find some of those elements
from a 19th century linguist
who travelled throughout the
Karamanlides- speaking regions
of Cappadocia and documented a
few of the remaining Greek words
that mostly the elderly
people spoke.
Karamanlides did not adapt the
Greek national identity of the time
but they preferred instead
to be called Rum, the Romans,
Christians of Christian Anatolia.
>> Selenay Aytac: Karamanlides
is one
of the many interesting
communities in need of the creation
of a niche personal community
knowledge environment
and an archetype for
similar conceptualization.
If we summarize what Constantia
just briefly mentioned,
Karamanlides also known
Karamanli people are those
who spoke Ottoman Turkish
and wrote in Greek characters
in Asia Minor during the
rule of the Ottoman Empire.
The Karamanli Turkish community has
been forced to leave the country
in accord with the 1923
Mubadele [inaudible]
so there is no more Karamanli
community left in Turkey anymore
and the cultural artifacts, all the
Karamanlides artifacts scattered
over the worldwide web are the
only evidence of their existence.
If we just look into the language
discourse again Karamanli Turkish is
spoken Ottoman Turkish
and recent Greek.
If we just go into Ottoman
Turkish case we see Ottoman Turkish
and Arabic [inaudible] and for Greek
is Greek spoken and Greek written.
So for the case of Karamanli
Turkish we see the combination
of a little bit changed Greek
alphabet manipulated just
to give some of the sounds
that Ottoman Turkish has
and spoken purely Ottoman Turkish.
And if you refer the
same scientist again,
the same scholar Mattias Kappler,
he pointed out that no individual
is perfectly monolingual.
No society is purely monocultural
and no human expression of arts
or any type of communication is
free from any external influence.
So, works that were published
in Ottoman Turkish using Greek
script are called Karamanlidika
or Karamanli Turkish
is the great example
of what scholar Kappler
mentioned, discussed in his works.
And works that are published
in Ottoman Turkish using Greek
scripts are the great example
of this cross-cultural concern
and it is exchanging
between two cultures.
And if I go back to my digital
library project we see that the aim
of the project was the discovery
of Karamanlides artifacts
but not just discovery of these
artifacts but also the reconnecting
of peoples to their cultural
heritage and their lost memories
by a digital platform,
a digital library.
And it was not just a digital
library project to start with,
one of the aims, objectives of
this project was to facilitate
in the long-term of course,
genealogy research among
these dispersed peoples
and common understanding of
cultural heritage, common cities
and shared countries such as Cyprus,
a country that remains divided
between Greek and Turkish Cypriots.
My methodology, the first step was
to identify available digital
Karamanlides cultural artifacts via
social media tools.
So I used Facebook, Twitter and
YouTube and I used some key words
to find, retrieve some Karamanlides
and pinpoint the useful
metadata for such a project.
And the next step focused
on the analysis
of these user-created,
generated metadata.
And based on the findings
of this study we found many
Karamanlides artifacts scattered all
over the worldwide web and most of
them lacking descriptive metadata.
Now I have a schema here if you can
see some of the artifacts listed.
Two artifacts retrieved by
Twitter and three of them
from Facebook and two from YouTube.
The first one is a book title
page of a book, a monograph,
found on Twitter by using
the key word, 'Karamanlidika'
and the date is clearly visible.
The date was 1784 and of course not
so much information on
this Twitter, tweet.
There is no information about
location and there is no translation
but in some cases you see that
there is a transliterational
Karamanlidika here.
And the second artifact I gathered
via Twitter was an inscriptive
stone, entry of the building and
of course we didn't have the date
or any information about this.
It was just a picture
of an inscriptive stone
with Karamanlidika on it.
And some other data gathered
from Facebook discussion groups,
Facebook is a great platform that
many people they get together
and they join to these groups and
they discuss the different images
and different surrogates.
They talk about the language.
They transliterate and they discuss
about the resources they upload
on these Facebook groups.
This one was also from
Cyprus [inaudible].
The person who took the picture
of this inscriptive stone,
entry of the house put the place
that it's taken at
Cyprus and the dates.
We guessed it's from 1900.
And this individual used the tags
'Karamanice' and 'Karamanlilar'.
These are two popular tags
used among Turkish researchers.
Turkish historians, they
use these Turkish tags.
And the next one was a photograph,
again found through these
Facebook discussion groups
and they use the tags
'Karamanlidika' and 'Karamanlilar'
so it was easier to
retrieve this one
with the common key words we use.
And it was the picture of an
orphanage from Cappadocia.
It's [inaudible] the current
region and it was suspected
that the date, it's 1911 or 1912.
And we found another
picture from Kayseri,
that we see a family picture,
five people altogether.
And it's also dated 1924 and a
relative post of this picture.
They are family photographs.
And they posted the picture and they
pointed that they are family members
and they look forward to if anybody
else knows the other relatives
or neighbors, information
about them.
And also we used YouTube to
find some other artifacts
and we found one oral
interview and one song.
And the oral interview
conducted in 2013
and she remembers how her relatives
came from Turkey and how they spoke
and how they sang and all the
information about the homeland
and the village they leave.
So, she had all this information
in this oral interview.
And she also had some
of the artifacts remain
from her grandmother that
they brought together,
some of the cooking utensils,
some other kitchen stuff.
So these are two great pieces
that we gathered from YouTube.
And if we go back to the digital
library prototype we presented
with the four-layer system.
And the first one we see
the content, metadata
and the second one is
system and network,
users and the management and policy.
In the content metadata
area we propose
that with this digital library users
can upload all the artifacts they
house in their family archives or
any other photographs they've taken
in these unique villages.
And they can just upload those
and they can also undertake
the information
about the Karamanlides artifacts.
And this proposed system
will store and will also help
to retrieve all these artifacts
and by using Control Vocabulary.
And in terms of users, users
are wearing multiple hats.
They are not just users, they
are also uploading their family
archives, their personal
archives about Karamanlidika.
And in the meantime
they are undertaking,
they are sharing their information
about these pieces and communicating
with other users and researchers.
And this proposed digital library
will also have some guidelines
and it's hoped that it will
also house mounted exhibitions
that anyone can come and
visit this digital library
and see monthly uploaded
Karamanlidika artifacts
and they can see them.
So, I just have an example of an
Entity Relationship Diagram here.
You see the Karamanlidika
is the most popular key word
but in some cases like in
that uploaded Facebook picture
they may use Karamanice.
They may use Karamanli.
They may use Karamanlilar.
But of course we will use this
authoritative entry Karamanlidika
and Karamanlides for
these resources.
Libraries, archives and museums
and other memory institutions
were the primary keepers
of cultural artifacts
before the invention
of the worldwide web
especially Web 2.0.
With the emergence of social media
everything is radically changed
and enhanced and the
public they start
to disseminate their
cultural heritage directly
and therefore they bypass
the memory institution
so such a digital library project
may be a good venue environment
that they can share all the
cultural artifacts they have.
So, it's also hoped that
this proposed digital library
with the project will be also the
cultural glue that creates bones
and cultural knowledge frame for
a cohesive Karamanlides community
in this distributed environment.
And it's hoped that this will also
facilitate genealogy research among
these dispersed people and common
understanding of cultural heritage,
common space and their shared
countries such as Cyprus
as we mentioned previously.
And it's also hoped that
Karamanlides will be a good example,
this digital library will be a good
example to some other communities
which are in similar need for the
creation of a digital library.
So, we talk about all these
cultural artifacts and families
and the researchers holding these
resources in their personal archives
and how about the Karamanlidika
monographs.
They are also dispersed all over
the world and they are housed
in a variety of libraries
and repositories.
And I have some examples here.
That's one of the Karamanlidika
books.
This is a famous song.
It's [inaudible] Yri
Sevdali Sarki on the top
and at the bottom the lyrics
of a very famous Turkish song.
Probably you heard
about [inaudible].
I was wondering you know if
you heard about [inaudible].
It reads as:
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So this is the first
part of this famous song.
So this is from the
Yri Sevdali Sarki,
an example of how Karamanlidika
was in those monographs.
And I have another example
of this special culture here.
This is the [foreign
language spoken].
When you read do you see that
this is the special documentation
of this special serving machine
purchase by a Karamanlides family.
And you see that this is coming
from [foreign language spoken]
It's [foreign language spoken]
and all the details about
this particular purchase done
by this family.
And I have another example,
the entrance of this monograph.
On the top you see the
Karamanlidika entrance
and you see the transliteration
at the bottom.
And when you read, when you
transliterate so this is something
as similar we would like to do
in the digital library whenever we
upload a Karamanlidika document we
would like to see the
transliteration so anyone can read
and understand the content or
description of the artifact.
We have:
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> Constantia Constantinou: So
in 2010 I returned to Cyprus
for my second Fulbright
and my objective then was
to bring these bi-communal
societies of the Turkish
and the Greek Cypriots
closer to each other
in understanding each
other's language
from the library's perspective.
Cyprus has always, always since
1960s had a U.N. presence as you see
in some of these pictures but
the communities lived together
until 1974 when there was
a division of the island.
My work with the librarians from
the Cypriot Turkish universities
and the Greek Turkish
universities that you see
in these pictures was very
collaborative, was very trusting.
It was very engaging until the two
communities came together to begin
to realize the commonalities
of their cultures,
their languages [inaudible] as well
as their professions, librarianship.
Trust was built to the point
where we opened each other's
special collections to discover
in those collections
the Karamanlidika book
that I was seeing for
the first time.
Some examples of those books are
here from their special collections
and for me to realize for the first
time these two cultures coming
together in sound in Turkish
Ottoman words with a Greek spelling
of the titles and the
text of the books.
Some of the elements of
the Karamanlidika book is
of course the special dots that
you see over the Greek letters
to indicate their Turkish
pronunciation of those words
and of course Arabic calligraphy
such as [foreign language spoken]
of Sultans of the Sultans
sealed on the books.
This particular book,
it was published
in Istanbul [foreign language
spoken] in I think in 1877
by an Armenian publisher.
So we see more than just one
culture or identity come together.
There is the Arabic
script and the Greek
and Turkish pronunciations
of these books.
Now, my colleague will talk a
little bit more about how we would
like to see these books depicted
into our catalogues and our ability
to discover them through
our systems.
>> Selenay Aytac: So, some of
these monographs are housed
in our libraries.
We search WorldCat and we analyzed.
We [inaudible] descriptions of
some of these Karamanli works
or the manifestations
of Karamanlidika.
So, we found Karamanlidika surrogate
records for Karamanlidika works
in these libraries and we examined
some of those MARC records and would
like to share our recommendations.
One of the university libraries,
Bogazici University Library
from Istanbul, Turkey where I had
my Fulbright research conducted is a
good place for many Karamanli
[inaudible] resources
and this is one of the
Karamanlidika works
that you can see the
bibliographic records.
And you see the title, this
is the "Tzinkiane Kizi"
and they transliterate the title
and they put the, as you see,
the publishing information.
But the only information in
the surrogate records indicates
that this is a Karamanlidika work
is the subject heading the '650
field' here.
It's Turkish language in Karamanli
and so this is how it describes
so if you're looking
for Karamanlidika
in Worldcat you will not be able
to retrieve these bibliographic
records nor you will be able to know
that Bogazici Library
has a great collection
of Karamanlidika monographs.
Another example is from
the Library of Congress.
And this is the newer edition
of a Karamanlidika work
[foreign language spoken].
It's a well-known work.
It's first published in
Karamanlidika but then later
on in 1986 they republished
and here you see
that there is title
information in notes area.
We see the Roman transcription
of the original Turkish
in Greek script published as
[foreign language spoken] Istanbul
so we see the date of the original
work but, and look at the subject.
It [inaudible] Turkish civilization
19th century in 651 MARC field
but we don't see anything about
Karamanlidika or Karamanlides.
Usually when you're looking for
Karamanlidika monographs you look
for the key word Karamanlidika
so here again we do
not have any indication
of the mostly-used key words in
the record nor a subject heading.
Another surrogate record
is from a British library
and this is also another
Karamanlidika work
in 245 we see has written
[foreign language spoken] so we see
that this is also published
in Constantinople in 1836
and we have some notes
fill in information.
Again, information about the
language Karamanli to Turkish
so this is how they describe
in the notes area Karamanli
to Turkish written in Greek
letters Romanized in the normal way
and there is no subject
heading so we really don't see
that any information
about the [inaudible]
of this particular work either.
So, our findings that results show
that published works representing
of the Karamanli literature are
dispersed all over the world
in a variety of libraries and
repositories however due to lack
of subject headings and Library of
Congress call numbers because some
of these resources are
classified and housed
in Turkish language sections,
some of them in modern Greek
language sections and some
of them are just waiting
to be catalogued.
So, due to lack of subject headings,
the Library of Congress
call numbers,
retrieving these works
is very problematic.
And there is no specific
bibliographic description used
for any of these Karamanli works.
In most of the information
library catalogues
as you saw the surrogate records,
they only use the notes area.
So our recommendations for
our colleagues at the Library
of Congress LC subject
heading, call number
and perhaps the language code.
We didn't mention that but usually
they use a 'tu' language code
for Turkish for all these
Karamanlidika works.
In some cases they
use the Greek codes
so we should be establishing
a new one for Karamanlidika.
And if I just summarize by
creating a new subject heading
for Karamanlidika or Karamanlides
we can organize all these monographs
under one subject heading and we
can make all the researchers' access
much easier to the
Karamanlidika works.
>> Constantia Constantinou:
And we would like to conclude
our presentation with this image
and a sound bite of a song.
These are Karamanlides.
As you see they're all gathered
together with instruments.
There are Turkish flags and
they're singing the Karamanli song.
Let me see if I can
get to this, great.
So, today we spoke of
Karamanlides people, their culture,
their language and their
literature as we have come
to experience that
from our research.
Our Fulbright assignments presented
the diversity and the commonalities
of these two distinct cultures and
the Turkish and the Greek cultures
and we believe that it
is our responsibility
to preserve their cultures,
their records
and to make them discoverable
through [inaudible]
of subject headings and descriptors.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Joan Weeks: So, we'd be happy to
have some questions from anybody.
Do people have questions?
Michael? Michael: [Inaudible] one
of my colleagues has catalogued
some Karamanli books and also books
in Turkish [inaudible]
Armenian [inaudible].
If you send your suggestions
to us, so,
we'll see what we can
do about [inaudible].
>> Selenay Aytac: That would
great, thank you very much.
>> Constantia Constantinou:
Michael, thank you again.
Can you just tell us a little bit
about the Armenian
Turkish literature?
I'm not very much familiar
with that.
>> Michael: I'm not the
one who is cataloguing it
but the Armenian cataloguer does not
know Turkish so when he gets a book
in Armenian script
and starts reading it
and realizes that it's not Armenian.
He brings it to us.
Usually he brings it to Alan
[assumed spelling] [inaudible]
and together they figure
out what it says.
But we've also gotten a
couple of books in Kurdish
in the Armenian script, particularly
translations of the Bible
and I often wonder who was
intended as the audience of that.
I mean who would only
know the Armenian alphabet
but speak Kurdish in 1875.
It's a bit of a mystery.
I mean who was the
intended audience?
>> Constantia Constantinou: That was
my experience too when I was working
with the rare book collections
of my Turkish Cypriot libraries
and my colleagues presented
me with those books
as if here, you speak Greek.
You understand Greek and
you could read what it said.
And I started reading
it and I was listening
to my Turkish pronunciation
of Allah, the great God
and I did not understand
a word I was reading
but they understood
everything of course, yeah.
>> Michael: Oh but I mean it was
known [inaudible] it was known
that they spoke Turkish but
wrote it in the Greek script.
>> Constantia Constantinou: Yes.
>> Michael: But there are.
I know of no Kurds who
spoke Kurdish but wrote it
in the Armenian script [inaudible].
>> Constantia Constantinou: Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Selenay Aytac: Another question?
>> Unidentified Speaker:
Location-wise [inaudible] survive
and still speak [inaudible].
I realize that [inaudible]
Turkey anymoe but [inaudible]?
>> Constantia Constantinou:
I met some of the children
and grandchildren of
Karamanlides in the United States.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Selenay Aytac: Yes, some of
the oral interviews conducted,
it was in Greece and after the
Mubadele they went to Greece
and different places and some of
them they came to the United States.
This is how I think she met
some of the grandchildren
so they dispersed all
over the world.
And I'm also a member
of this Facebook group.
It's called Scattered
Greeks that they talk
about their great-great parents
and their families and they try
to learn more about their
transcendental homelands that,
they've never been there but
the only image in their head is
through their grandmas' stories.
But they talk about these places
and they know the villages
that they're born but they've
never been to Turkey either.
So, just like this summer we
met some of the researchers
from Australia and New Zealand.
They were planning to come to
Turkey to see the land that some
of their great parents they mention
and they talk about the Gallipoli
and so I think they're
all over the world.
I also met some Australian
Greeks that they are looking
for some information about
their family roots in Anatoli,
so I think they're
all over the world.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
I'm just fascinated
with your digital library project
and I see how you're using
transliterations [inaudible] one
of the most difficult things
with putting them together
of digital library
[inaudible] different scripts
or [inaudible] field to
put things in Arabic,
Chinese [inaudible] languages and
I think we're not there with Greek
yet in the cataloguing process.
So could you describe some of your
efforts [inaudible] digitalize?
>> Selebay Aytac: Yes, this is
just in the preparation stage yet
and of course we cannot propose
an automated system because it's
such a special language and requires
a special skill of transliteration
as you all appreciate that you need
two experts just like in the case
of Armenian correctors and
Turkish, you need both knowledge
of Armenian letters,
knowledge of Ottoman Turkish,
not the regular Turkish because
the Turkish they speak right now,
currently, is also different.
They had the language revolution.
A lot of words have been left
behind so you really need someone
who can speak the Turkish of that
time that they created those words.
So you need multiple language
expertise so it's almost impossible
to create such an automated system.
So the proposed library will
have users wearing multiple hats
[inaudible] and uploading the
images of Karamanlidika works
and then transliterating
by themselves in the system
with the help of some other users.
So this is the plan for
the system and it's still
in the process of working.
We have another question, comments?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Well, I received a Fulbright
to go to country Turkey
and organize some workshops and
meet the specialists and librarians
and at the first stage we had
the proposal of digital library
and the architecture
of the digital library
but we didn't complete
any technical work yet.
So, and the Bogazici University
was a great host and they hosted me
and I spent there my
Fulbright research
and they had two scholars,
researchers.
They helped me to put
the webpage together just
to disseminate the information
because you can surprise
that there are so many
people out there,
they never heard of Karamanlidika.
They don't know about these
hidden gems of literature.
I mean we know about Turkish
literature, Ottoman literature,
Greek, Armenian but we don't
know about these works created
in between those different cultures.
So, the first stage was to really
disseminate what we're planning
to do and gather support so the
technical part did not start yet
and the plan is if everything
goes well with the university
and the staff to apply for a
grant so we can hire people
to put the system together so we can
start uploading some family archives
because I am also a Facebook
member of some of these groups
that they have huge
documentation in their own houses
and they don't know how to share.
I mean we're all using Facebook.
We post a lot of things.
It just disappears in Facebook.
The major problem in
Facebook in terms of sharing,
it's not really retrievable and if
you cannot retrieve what is in there
as you know, the main objective
of a library catalogue,
it should be retrievable so
Facebook is not the best place
so share those types of resources.
So all these people they're
ready to share what they have
at somewhere else,
on a better platform.
So hopefully once we
have the funding
and put the technical
system, digital library
out there we will have many
people supporting the creation
of this library.
>> Constantia Constantinou: We also
came to know a lot of scholars,
Greeks and Turks through a
conference that they hosted
for a second time and there's a
publication of their essays called
"Cries and Whispers
of Karamanlidika".
There were about 50 some scholars
who continue to do this kind of work
and I think really their essays
in that conference were extremely
eye-opening for both of us
to realize that there is some true
scholarship there that we need
to capture the history behind it.
>> Joan Weeks: Thank you so
much, both of you [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
>> Constantia Constantinou:
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov